france24 y radio francia internacional a
punto de ser suspendidos de malí la
junta militar lo anunció a través de un
comunicado teniendo en cuenta la
sincronización de este bombo mediático
el gobierno deduce de ello una
estrategia premeditada para
desestabilizar la transición
desmoralizar al pueblo maliense y
desacreditar a las valientes fuerzas
armadas son la junta acusa de mentir y
se basa en tres fuentes una declaración
de la alta comisionada para los derechos
humanos de las naciones unidas michelle
bachelet un informe human right watch y
un reportaje de efe y el grupo de
comunicación público francés negó las
acusaciones y explorará todas las formas
de recurso un rechazo que llegó hasta la
unión europea
lo consideramos inaceptable lamentamos
de esta decisión y las acusaciones
infundadas al atacar la libertad de
prensa de informar y ser informado la
junta continúa y confirma su huida hacia
adelante ntx
este martes 15 de marzo en el informe de
human rights watch se dijo que desde
diciembre de 2021 el ejército de mali
había sido response de la muerte de 71
civiles un reporte publicado un mes
después del anuncio de la retirada de
tropas francesas de malí la presencia de
francia en malí se remonta a 2013 cuando
intervino en el norte del país contra
los extremistas islámicos allí disponía
de 2.400 soldados de los 4.300 que ha
tenido en distintos puntos del sahel así
migoya al líder de la junta llegó al
poder en agosto de 2020 y en un segundo
golpe de estado destituyó a los líderes
civiles desde entonces ha crecido el
sentimiento antifrancés
apoyamos a nuestros líderes francia no
debe permanecer más en mali de hecho en
el comunicado de expulsión contra
france24 y radio francia internacional
son comparados con la radio mil colin
que alentó el genocidio en ruanda de